well we are out of time for it tonight  but Kevin I am so ready to hit the Emmys  on Sunday got the dress I'll fit it I'm  ready to go yeah you know Nancy I don't  think people out there realize that you  keep your dress secret from me until the  moment you hit the red carpet I see you  and I go whoo look at her  can't wait for Sunday I'll meanwhile  recently I was hanging out with my man  Kevin Hart you know he is morphed into  his alter ego the rapper chocolate drop  up no this is real he has a record deal  and everything and he is calling out  other rappers check this out what  rappers are you on par with well I mean  I think real question is with rappers  are on par with me you know asking me  who I'm on par with it's like asking you  so wise a pig's tail curly I used to  talk with these and I'm not going back